[Music]
so just quick introduction who who are
we who is Accenture federal services so
let's start with Accenture LLP global
firm four hundred sixty thousand plus
people serving eight eighty percent of
the fortune 500 clients extension
federal services is a wholly owned
subsidiary and so we're about ninety
five hundred plus people mostly located
in the DC area and we serve only federal
government so we don't do any state or
local so it's all the three-letter
agencies that you can you can talk to
talk about so what does that look like
exactly and so we like starting here to
just kind of set the set set stage in
terms of the scope of our solutions and
the problem sets that were were
attacking so three hundred and twenty
million customers is our is our customer
base for trillion dollars is the budget
of the federal government there's
millions and millions of vehicles if you
think about the Army and the DoD Air
Force even the US Postal Service has
over a million vehicles that they're
tracking in terms of maintenance cost
and you know collisions and insurance
and repairs and about two and a half
million employees so that's the largest
employer in United States and there's
one of the largest employers in the
entire world so anytime we're talking
about rapid prototyping anytime we're
talking about our solutions these are
global problems with hundreds of
millions of people that are being
affected anyone know what this image is
it's the last image of the Curiosity
rover that just went dark a couple of
weeks ago a couple months ago now and
its last message that's pretty poetic
this is like a poetic interpretation my
battery is low and it's getting dark so
the reason I put this up here is again
to kind of prove a point of where our
problem space is so curiosity was
launched 14 years ago so 2005 think
about the technology that you had with
you in 2005 right it's flip phones you
know I was still in college you know I
had much longer hair I was in the
engineering for
right looked a little different but we
sent you know this piece and hunk of
metal through space into another planet
and it lasted 14 years it's only
supposed to last like two years or three
years and they're the exact but it
lasted fourteen years and it sent back
all these amazing pictures including
this which is not stars this is actually
just a sandstorm it's a fuzz it looks
really cool but it was its last image
yeah and to really add on to what Dave
you know kind of just honed in on the
problem landscape that our government
faces is extremely vast and complex and
to that point there's a room for
innovation all over whether we're
talking about again
DoD come came up with a GPS vaccines
health and longevity the problems are so
complex it'd be really nice to you know
invite our commercial partners in and
try to solve everything for us but the
government is on their own in a lot of
in a lot of cases and they're working
hard and again that's important to wrap
the prototype yeah and these are these
are game-changing innovations life
changing innovations world scale
innovations the internet right where
would we all be without the internet no
that was an innovation an investment
from the federal government Google
National Science Foundation we wouldn't
be here without investments from the
government and so how do we solve these
massive problems these intergalactic
problems you know these world-changing
problems quickly we use rapid
prototyping so we both work outside of
the Accenture federal digital studio so
we have a very cool you know sleek urban
place down in in Washington DC you know
lots of wood and exposed beams and and
hip people with cool laptops and cool
haircuts and cool shoes solving these
problems and so we kind of approach the
problem in four different ways so vision
and organization value and design
technology and scaling I'm going to step
through in detail what we mean about
each of those but first it's kind of our
mindset it's the Michelin star
restaurant versus a Zagat restaurant so
when we do delivery for our federal
customers when we're
on a project for agency X and we bring
our domain expertise to solve those
mission problems that's our Zagat
approach you know that's the Mexican
restaurant that has the best burrito in
the entire city and they make that
burrito every single day and they do it
real excellent we take the Michelin star
approach right so every night we have a
different menu a tasting menu we work
with seasonal ingredients we work at the
latest technology blockchains sure let's
try to add blockchain to something right
cloud services sure the new cloud
services that were just announced this
morning anthos right we're gonna already
start playing with that here my lead a
DevOps engineers ready to get his hands
on them so vision and organization I
really like starting with this because I
think every time you're approaching a
problem you have to think about where
you're gonna be currently we're gonna be
three months six months 18 months and
five years out right it's the road that
you're running towards so we have
capabilities and we have solutions so
capabilities are our verticals you know
we're you're not gonna do be everything
to everybody
we're gonna do web and mobile
development we're gonna do DevOps we're
gonna do platforms I want to do applied
intelligence and they're gonna have our
solutions right and so later on today
we're not going to just bore you to
death by PowerPoint we're gonna show you
a bunch of our actual rapid prototypes
where we're gonna build and one of those
solutions is the next-generation contact
center that Mike's been working on
really really hard over the last two
weeks
and then again people so I want to
iterate on this point the type of people
that we're bringing into our
organization are non-traditional people
mike has a background in FinTech we have
people who are econ background people
who are non traditional federal
consultants and we bring them because
they bring a wider range of thinking to
these hard problems
but most important and I have it bolded
at the bottom there is the ability to
learn right so we're working with the
new with things that are announced in
the morning right there's nobody who's
an expert there's no job description
that I can post and say you know let's
have five years of you know anthos
experience it just doesn't exist
so we need to adapt on the fly valley
indesign so me and mike work very
closely together with our human centered
design team it's a human centered design
that was kind of new term to me when i
started working for for the extension
federal digital studio and it's
basically a fancy way of saying we put
the human first right we don't take the
technology first approach how's the
human interacting with the systems
what's the human problem what's the
human experience and so we do these
things they're called design sessions we
bring in all of our stakeholders we
bring in the operators we bring in the
security experts we bring in smart folks
like Mike who are you know have an
engineering background and we all get in
a big room you know it's very granola
but it's very effective and we do sticky
notes and whiteboards and we come up
with you know here's the main issues
here's what we want to solve okay and
then you know once we start going
through like let's iterating on like the
technology approach and how do we
actually you know is it feasible and
what's the return on investment like you
know maybe we can solve it but it costs
100 million dollars and the problem you
know it's only a $500,000 type of
problem okay well let's not actually do
that and then you know we talk about our
business process redesign and user
interface and user experience and
something we like to talk about within
the studio is our liquid approach so
liquid expectations what does that mean
that means our customer base are 320
million customers that we're supporting
within the federal government have
expectations that their day-to-day lives
that their interactions with the federal
government are gonna be the same as
their day-to-day life so they pull up a
phone app and they order a car it's a
touch of a button
they want to have that same simple
experience when they're interacting with
IRS Social Security whatever age they're
going to get their driver's license
renewed
how do we do this yes so um a rapid
prototyping team essentially a software
development team is not like your
traditional development team right if
I'm on a contract
you know one to five years we're gonna
get you know some pretty strict
requirements on what it is we're
developing right and with that I can go
out and search for a developer why who
has capability X and I can you know be
pretty stringent on my interviewing them
to you know figure it out they're gonna
be really capable of doing this job like
Dave said earlier we're not looking for
that within our team we need generalists
that can solve again any one of these
problems in this vast landscape of
problems so why we do want to
standardize on efficiencies like
JavaScript that's you know kind of taken
over the full stack and even getting
into the data world a bit we want to
lean heavily on our vendor partners and
manage services and you know be able to
provide custom integrations into cool
capabilities like cloud mlah
engine or a contact center ai and we
want engineers who can do that with
Python because maybe that's what our
clients are working with and their
current systems maybe they're working on
Salesforce CRM or maybe it's ServiceNow
and the way those api's work need to be
configured differently and Salesforce
has its own programming language again
we just want those generalist engineers
capable of taking on any problem and
solving it you know with the constraints
that they're given and to that point
engineers are lazy I mean they're
efficient so any mundane tasks that kind
of falls below a value line of you know
mission value like if I'm writing code
most of time the application I'm writing
most of code I'm writing for this
avocation I'm hoping is producing some
type of value for the end user
anything that's not you know we're
talking about infrastructure logging in
into VM scaling out the underlying
platform we want to automate that as
much as possible so we have awesome
engineers like Jordan Taylor here who
sets up an entire infrastructure for us
in kubernetes and pivotal Cloud Foundry
and Red Hat again a broader range of
technologies because we won't be able to
provide for all our clients the same way
that we do internally in terms of
development and you know providing
efficiencies in that regard so we talked
about a problem set we talked about how
we organized our rapid prototyping team
now how do we actually go about and
implement this so say we start with our
problem statement right
there's a federal agency they have a
legacy support desk and
trying to think about modernization you
know modernization means a lot of things
to a lot of different people across the
stakeholders and so they're they're
trying to balance the risk between you
know maintaining that domain expertise
for the people who've been supporting
the mission for years and years and you
know and costs like costs are a real
driver and using automation and
generally using automation to help
improve the domain experts and
ultimately you know deliver a better
value experience to the end customer and
so you have some people that are viewing
this you know all right well they you
know they control the purse strings
let's introduce CRM tools let's
introduce art automation it's gonna
drive down our contracting costs you
know we'll have more revenue to invest
in additional areas or maybe you know
because they're federally funded their
budget got cut this year from for a
political reason or maybe have people
we've seen this before
you know the CRM tools it won't fit
within our mission like people won't
adopt it you know is this the same story
we've gone through up again it doesn't
work never does and then some people you
know they've been doing their job for 20
years and they don't want to change they
think the the way they've created is the
best way to get it done and then some
people were you know let's be route
there's the human element some people
when there's automation and technology
being introduced that's new they get
worried you know people have families to
support they're worried about job loss
right and so we need to take into
consideration all of these different
stakeholders all of these different
concerns all these different risks you
know the people the technology the cost
into how we actually build the problems
and so we think rapid prototyping is a
really good way to do this because we
can fail fast we can build something
very quickly and when I say quickly I'm
talking about one day one week using one
or two engineers or two weeks with one
person grinding out building out the
next generation contact center which
we're gonna show you in a couple minutes
and then actually get that friend of our
customers really quickly and getting the
end users feedback and then iterating
over that so the development team you're
a prototype you team you want to take
that problem statement and you want to
be careful with how you unpacked it
right hopefully you're leaning and
leaning in heavily on
you know design methods and
methodologies such as human centered
user centric design that way you're
working with the team who really
understands that problem they'd given
you but with that I want I want our team
to be keen on that problem too because I
don't want to take a problem and develop
something that's not gonna resonate or
that's not gonna be useful or worst-case
that you know can never be implemented
with a certain federal client right we
really need to consider you know what's
gonna be feasible to a certain extent
you know when would be fit for federal
in terms of compliance current systems
current solutions and integrations then
we can move into you know a layer of
usability and okay well is it what we're
gonna build be you know it's gonna be
usable like again in the context of
federal it's pretty important and then
useful this is where we get to have fun
all right how can we you know add some
spice how can we add some pizzazz and
really make any solution we develop
within two weeks cool and then if with
that on top if we're if we done these
things we're gonna have some time to
really provide some efficiencies with
the solution and if we're providing any
type of solution that makes the mission
more efficient for end-users
hopefully that provides you know a
joyful experience if I want to get from
point A to point B and I can push a
button somebody's gonna come pick me up
and take me there that's a joyful
experience there's that that exists all
over the federal landscape cool so back
to the problem statement we have a
Service Desk legacy service that's been
shut down some we have a CRM that's been
brought into the bureaus or bureaus
organization and they want to know how
to use it they say they come to our
group say you know how we can use this
thing it's not really fit in our mission
how can make it relevant you know we've
got in the budget to you know explore AI
to explore you know some cool solution
you know what can we do help us and what
we're about to demonstrate is
essentially that mix how do you
pronounce the day yeah so about nine
months ago we were very lucky to be at
it as an alpha partner for contact
center AI and so this is what you're
about to see is our second generation of
working through that we built out one
over the last six months and we showed
it to a lot of our federal customers as
they came
through and got a lot of feedback in
terms of you know how does this
integrate with our CRM tool how do you
have omni-channel support and so what
we're about to show you in a couple
minutes this is our reference
architecture we've worked with Google as
a strong partner we worked with
Salesforce as our CRM tool that we've
integrated and then Twilio we're gonna
show you an omni-channel the ability to
call to telephony live streaming to an
operator and having agent assist working
in place so that means I'm actually
having a customer calling an operator
I'm splitting off of that that actual
raw audio file doing transcription
on-the-fly searching a knowledgebase and
then in real time showing that
knowledgebase to my operator so that
they can resolve the issue of the
customer faster and more efficient
providing them the information that they
need and we're using contact center AI
and dialogue flow to create a single
virtual agent that you can interact with
via chat text or text or telephony can't
miss anything he's the engineer he's the
smart guy I've actually built this okay
so we made a very California demo
it's about avocados and so with that if
we can switch to the live demo screen so
what everybody's seeing right here is
our Salesforce operate our pain so this
is an example of what your support desk
operator would see and I'll walk through
the different panels and what they mean
and again just the level set this is two
weeks of Mike's time doing some
engineering as you know his part-time
jobs to get ready for this we were
grinding this out to be truthful last
night like true engineers do and by last
night I mean like two hours ago that's
when we finally got it working and we
rushed here and the support staff was
extremely gracious to let us run through
this in practice to make sure that phone
calls worked with the Mike's so we're
not nervous at all because it'll work it
worked a little bit ago but it is a
world premiere so enjoy Mike's gonna
play the role of our avocado researcher
or farmer whatever one he decides to
pick and I'll be up to him and then
let's get started
so I'm a researcher on the field and I'm
experiencing some issue and I've been
told I've got this intelligent service
desk I can call a call to begin some
insights and context that maybe the
virtual agent that couldn't give me that
may work with and we'll show you the
virtual agent chat afterwards so I'm
calling and it's going through the cost
infrastructure now Tullio provides our
David he is phone which we make sure he
capped off the last one there we go
looks like Mike Ramos avocado researcher
is calling me
hi mr. Ramos how can I help you today
hi I'm experiencing issues on my avocado
farm all right so we're gonna pause here
and there's a lot to unpack of what just
what just happened right it was it seems
pretty simple so I'm over here and in
case there was a little laser pointer of
some sort okay so Mike built a mobile
application that takes his voice and
actually does the transcription on a
client so it does the transcription on
the phone just because in terms of
latency that's a lot faster than sending
the raw audio to dialogue flow having
dialogue flow do the transcription and
then do some of the intent matching so
he's the mobile app is actually
splitting the audio file so the audio
file is being sent we couldn't get the
because of the mics and so like that the
way you could hear it but we actually
have it set up so you can do the talking
back and forth between the operator and
the transcription is being sent to
dialogue flow and contact center AI to
actually do three things one the top
here or suggested responses it's
interpreting what Mike was saying asking
about his avvocato problems and it
snatching it to our knowledge base so
our knowledge base is literally key
values it's questions and answers so
tries to match it on the question what
you see here and if I expand it as the
operator I have some suggested content
that I can ask back now at the bottom
here suggested fulfillment this is where
it's matching on intense so intense are
think of them as more static type of
workflows your generic chat bot type of
interface so if Mike was calling about
password resets we might match sure says
you know easy way to reset a password
click a button had that fulfillment
working we have it implemented right now
but the actual interface isn't we didn't
get to that yet but might create a
machine learning model that predicts the
future prices of avocados yeah that's
the other part we use cloud ml engines
to essentially create a model a
regression model that this researcher
might want to use on the field given you
know the data they're collecting and
then an intent that's built in that
would show up is you know just price
insight on you know this potential field
in crop yield and what you would see
there is you know that's just being
integrated into Salesforce and then
plugging in with you know your relevant
Salesforce data sets and then third most
exciting part over here is related
documents so we uploaded a bunch of PDFs
you can upload HTML essentially its
unstructured information and that's when
Mike's asking a question we're doing the
transcription it's pulling out the
entities and it's going through that
unstructured text and it's actually
finding which relevant documents that he
might be sending that I might send him
and so I might be able to send you know
share this link with Mike the avocado
researcher on you know choosing an
avocado variety I'm sorry I'm not an
expert in avocados yet all right so I'm
gonna ask Mike you know I'm sorry to
hear that you have problems with your
your avvocato how can I help you more
specifically I'll make specifically I'm
experiencing problems with the root rot
so I see went through it actually pulls
up different suggestions you know there
are fungicides Mike that are available
from the nursery and there are a number
of things you can do before applying
something like that so instead of an
operator having the you know listen
interpret open up another system do a
search I have this right here I can do a
call resolution much faster you know
typically you want to want your rapid
prototype prototyping cycles to be you
know just two weeks give it four weeks
this becomes a full integration within
Salesforce full integration within you
know creating actual reports and
distributing throughout the CRM to the
right people
all right that's that's it well thank
you everybody for your time we're here
if you want to talk to us really
appreciate you attending the session
[Music]